oh-oh-oh we found it we found it we
found it mob found it wait we thought
we'd come over wait come over it
TP TP wing Wade Wade Wade Wade Wade Wade
he's not his webcams on the corner huh
Wade wide what did he leave I don't know
did he run off and go somewhere with
Molly most likely I don't know
oh they're probably having the sex you
know doing the drugs God to him yeah him
and his girl ah man it's so wait a
minute they look at all these footprints
here I went on when he yeah a fight
happened here with something that's not
human you know me you're gentle shut up
al oh shut up about that
something here isn't right these tracks
lead off to this way wait no this way
this you mean and place where there are
no tracks Sean this way
oh they loop around in a circle and they
come over here and oh my god which it
Wow they're Salim why are there so many
aliens I don't know
we got away we gotta hide we got to hide
in this crater I didn't know crater
oh my god oh is this oh you got across
I got a crossbow huh I have the worst
feeling they took way you know I think
you might be right nice time for my
music to kickin they took way what music
I got minecraft music really eerie stuff
did they uh you're ruining my moment
they took way he'd
so we have to get him back right Bob
that's the plan or or wai-wai-wait what
do we want wait back cuz it's in the
script that we got right here huh we
don't want Wade back we just want it
okay okay so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna go in there I'm gonna kill
all of the aliens for taking and
probably Wow why not half of a heart
left this is gonna be very problematic
when we're killing aliens why did I get
to y-yeah you say I need to steal my
nerves with them drink all right
right now yah thanks okay then
all right heel all right I'll I'll be
the banner man and you charge in there
with your boomerang that you just threw
it'll come back okay I'm better I'm
gonna be the Bannerman I'm gonna play my
flute and bang my drums while you kill
them okay all right okay I'll get the
musket boy you're all we can both do the
banner and I'll draw my musket when we
get closer okay sounds good all right
wait the Purple's of their eyes okay
yes are their eyes purple I'm gonna I'm
gonna believe you on this one okay
probably Dada Dada Dada Dada Dada
ah they're so clear it's a little baby
one ah got it
kill it before it breeds ah oh this is
gonna take forever I'm impaling them
with the American flag be proud of me my
home country wait hang on this baby
this baby's not dying I'll hit it with
the crossbow Hannah all right wait kind
of stupid-ass crossbow they got it I got
one I got the little one it's dead it'll
never attack wait again do they fight
back yeah just assume yes but they're so
scared cuz we're so awesome yeah it's
got to be it right right right Bob right
Bob a snipe I'm gonna snipe from the
hillside let's stay up here oh god
there's one behind us dude what where
kill it kill it dead am kill it harder I
got it I got it it was coming right for
you look up
our week how are we supposed to kill all
these things we're just just got to keep
drowning in their blood until they're
finally all gone I'm surprised there are
so many children here but I mean it's
kind of a horrible massacre but
nonetheless look right in our face as I
should ha ha ha ha ha I'm aiming at them
with the gun and they're all Oh what you
doing there wait about it
flutter you do there's a witch over here
there's a moon which I got killed
move move ha ha ha ha
ah so ridiculous oh ok alright I think
that's enough I think that's enough
murder for two dolly Brian come back to
me look at how they're coming right for
Oh
I got hang on I got I got him you did
good good job sir ah that was a close
one we've got to ha it's looking right
at us
they were coming off right behind you
man huh oh man I'm glad you're you've
got my BOB oh no oh I lost all my
everything so jar ah killed Bob oh my
god that's not good oh ah I got a
runaway wait hang on come back here you
there's all your stuff tosser increment
attacking me ha ha port to me with your
magical powers you know
moon powers moon powers I killed the
moon which and it gave us my powers it's
all down there in a big circle of death
why did you kill me I was trying to hit
the thing those trying to kill you then
you got in the way now I'm just cleaning
up the rest of them this crossbow is
very powerful by the way like
ridiculously but I have no bullets ha ha
there are bullets around ears there
bullets up here up here where I am those
get to bullets up here and I'd go
everything oh by the way hi everybody
I was watching welcome to drunk
minecraft hope you enjoyed our theatrics
we're gonna continue with the soiree
until we find Wade who is mysteriously
excuse me I'm spitting
was mysteriously missing right Bob yeah
we have no idea where he is it's really
weird no idea even though he told us I
we just we don't know he's yeah bangin
my sexin oh my god
there are so many aliens why are you
know I'm in a house I'm clearing out
this family that looked very scared but
I knew there was just there firing out
this family
this little kid and a whole bunch of
people just standing there in the corner
they look pretty scared but I knew they
were just trying to kill me so it's all
it's all about survival oh the look at
this little kid hiding in the corner of
a window just like cowering here oh
don't worry I'll protect you and he'll
dad done oh my gosh
okay Bob what have we become Bob wait
come here come here Bob I found
something I watch which whoa oh my god
there's another wish Oh Oh otherwise
okay that'll take priority from my
horrifying discovery
don't let me shoot you okay I gotta get
from the witch I don't know what did you
get from the wig I got a stick hey Bob
wait come here oh no Bob don't look Bob
don't Joe Bob he almost killed me wait
now you're not looking at Bob no turned
into a block Asst you bastard
Oh No Oh Oh can I plant my flag like
right on oh oh wait yeah what am i doing
I'll plant your flag in wait Brooklyn oh
wait I threw to the corner
what the hell that's all right flag god
damn it wait oh wait hahahaha
did hahahaha oh no poor Wade okay so now
that we've found waves mangled corpse of
sand what are we going to do afterwards
uh that was the whole thing that was the
whole thing we're supposed to find it so
close know that I had something planned
for after it like we gotta get Wade back
home to his family to his reveal not
Widow Molly here I've got an idea
okay I'm ready it's not the right idea
I'm ready for it uh lay it on me
just get just it's hang on mmm-hmm I
yeah no no it's it's it's you're it's
numbing mm-hmm just cool mmm here you go
okay huh I can only place things on oh
man ha ha ha ha
so you're saying we need to build a
roller coaster yeah out of here
the railroad okay to honor wait for Wade
we will build the moon Railroad to get
him home get him home to his loved ones
I'm gonna get just a infinite amount of
powered rail and I'm going to help you
out here
wait a minute powered rail doesn't turn
oh I'll come back with the regular rail
and then you okay never mind you'll do
it alright fine you don't need me Wow
just get the hell out of here I got a
brave all the evil entities that are
plaguing this place and by that I mean
aliens with their helpless families that
looked looked innocent but until I shot
him in the face and you murdered the
[ __ ] out I murdered I murdered them so
good no just like when I killed that
baby in the in the cyndago video and the
dog cuz everyone loved that
I thought that was the funniest thing
sauce that was a funny thing ever but no
one has a sense of humor not one anyway
what what am I saying
Marga by our approves of baby killing
and pop what I want five seven year olds
on the stage so I put a Syrah
I saw me get out treasure energy I'll
tease room again how many can we bus in
for this Oh God
that would Brian Regan everybody Brian
Regan oh that was marks uh uh yeah else
Brian rigged up Brian Regan I can't take
credit for that that was low my god does
a creeper here why is there a space
creeper uh uh why am i punching it I
have a freaking crossbow go move creeper
I jumped grippers gonna jump hey jumpin
turns out they can apparently moon
creepers can jump god I know killed it I
killed it dead alright I'm powering the
rail where are you building rail - I
don't know everywhere why are you
building it that way I went this way
good this this feels food Milky Way ergh
Bob
sorry just by instinct I say wait what
who's wait stead mark weight is - booth
okay
I think you'll really like the materials
that I'm using to build the road here um
okay oh yes yes very yes is this is
exactly this is this is appropriate this
is what Wade would want this is how he
would want it it's not what he deserves
but it's it's what waves
we're not the heroes that Wade is hearse
here he needs
we're not the friends that he deserves
he deserves less good more I don't know
I don't know we're trying to bring him
back to earth to earth so that he could
be with his family but no how do we
where's this going then ah ah that's
about ah cut cut cut huh I almost killed
you I almost killed you
okay good job on that one dude this one
right behind you Thomas these fakes are
creepy they're just popping up
everywhere I don't know no I hear so
many no no okay anyway so we need to
build this railroad while we still can
it's dangerous out here Bob
we're never like that KP show that
everyone loves everyone loves everyone
hates Chris down oh oh uh oh uh
spaceship one spaceship one
yeah spaceship one spaceships and sg-1
spaceship Atlantis no no no no spaceship
there's another one goodbye that's not
weird
get out of here why is that that is not
right okay anyway I'm gonna get fight
them off you keep building okay all
right uh it's uh wait a minute just said
you fight him off yeah well they're gone
now
what what the hell you just told me to
do it like ten seconds ago well you
didn't so okay fine late you know what
I'm gonna do
oh you know I'm I do build your own
space railroad with a curse and
blackjack no I'm gonna replace all axes
with Kay's what do you think of that you
thinking I'm just not gonna do it
buddy what do you think of that Bob
Yuuka tupid AK hole you you could you
you could Inc that's what you do no
yours oka Tinky and and your your face
is pinky your face is your face yes what
Star Trek me what has s in it that's an
insult uh cooping you're in the advert
said Coutu peed so many times it's not
an insult anymore it's just it's not
good I gotta wait hang on I got it I got
it I got to god damn some of them your
face kick oh don't do that that's not
how we do it Oh how do you do it what
are you doing what are you doing why are
you breaking that no diamond really
really oh really Bob you think that I'm
gonna get
I'm gonna go get weighed you know what
I'm going to get weighed
I'm gonna ask him see how he what he
would want he will my god
I forgot that when I use diamond it's
really hard to break if I'm not so
there's another moon creeper in this
hand I need to get moon creeper no moon
alien mom I'm cart my cart with TNT
whammy come Lenny
that's your whammy come blame you - Rudy
- to a Manchu T Firefly that's not
thinking out it's just okay
alright I got the block wait where'd the
block is Han go wait what that oh no
it's over okay wait I've got you way
displayed even though he's an inanimate
object ha ha shut up
alright I'm pushing weight along the
track he's going he's going to a better
place dolphin oh ok enough that hopping
in the minecart no wait and hang on
there we go okay I'm moving I'm coming
I'm over I'm on my way
I hope this works correctly oh my god
there's a space creeper where don't let
it get weighed
don't go I'd Hanuma whoa what happened
wait wait he's up in the sky do you see
this wait what wait Bob I think Wade is
still alive somehow he left from the
minecart and landed on this block of
dirt Bob Bob Bob yeah finding space Bob
I think Wade's alive
ah alright Bob you're holding him in
your head Wade's talking to me Bob oh
you know what he's saying
ah dragon after universe to me I'll die
the way it wants me to die weights got a
cat oh no he's gone crazy
kill word okay Dumbo ah ha ha wait if it
did oh crap it musket broke ha ha ha the
waves stupidity has infected me yeah oh
yeah
puns what does way to say what something
stupid the blade says tell me something
stupid the way it says oh no no I'm Wade
well you see you would say that that's
exactly what he would think you me ask
me somebody I don't know ho ho ho Oh
Dinah [ __ ] Oh God ha ha that's like
forever I exploded ha ha ah stuff
explode ah I can't breathe
Hey look there's a moon pod I'm getting
out of here wait hang on no wait
whoa hello still can't breathe I'm okay
I'm okay
hey I've got Wade now oh is Wade taking
over your mind ow no Wade stop this
crossbow is much more deadly this is for
everything I will hook it up damn it
hang on hold still hold still you're
wearing oxygen monster I know wha wha
wha wha wha
now where's Wade I don't need oxygen if
I have wait what where does yeah right
I've gotta get out of you with why it's
a giant rocket ship Wade no way tell me
me and Wade we're running off into the
sunset together so bad ha ha ha Oh No ha
ha ha ha oh no oh this is the most fun
I've ever had
God okay why is there no oxygen guilt
spawn some oxygen mask a douche was
trying not to do that but will you
respond our rocket ship didn't do that I
can't do that anymore
ha ha oh [ __ ] hello you want me to give
you some yes here okay here's that
here's that is two oxygen tanks there
you go now you're all good
me worse than I don't have a head look
behind you yes stupid douche
I don't have a helmet you've just you
just you just got a ride
now where's ya where did Wade go is is
he gone forever
hey whoa whoa whoa whoa Wow
where's Wade Wade I think I think Wade
and I oh I haven't found him I didn't
find anything
Bram I found nothing uh I found nothing
you you didn't uh why is there a cow
here what's in a cow that suddenly
appeared here Moo why do you Castle Oh
beautiful keep singing
every time you are near Oh was that an
actual song uh yeah okay so what the
hell I know that's what I said was a cow
in the mines guard even dying on a moon
Oh we'll go after it I never minds not
worth it okay but anyway our final
mission Bob is we have to get back to
earth
oh I have supplies for that we have to
go back we have to go back Bob do you
have Wade I don't know course not Wade's
best left on the moon right Bob huh yeah
I think so yeah totally so we shouldn't
bring Wade back to earth i if that's
what you really want
that's it's what's best just get some
beef on the way back so to set up your
rocket ship and let's let's go back to
earth
err here I'll hook you up - we'll do
this together okay okay best super best
friends group Club yeah definitely
what the what what what what happened
what did you see something on did you
see something out of here all right
I'm coming with you yeah you know we
won't be able to land on earth right you
know this right I have a parachute
I do not hang on I want a parachute ha
ha ha ha
wait hang on para wait did I just do
para chute parachute ha ha ha what
happened
why where'd you do ha ha ha
I gave you a booby-trapped one obviously
hey hey I'm coming after you
best of the Rockets I don't even need a
launch pad I'm coming to get you
I just dropped him out of the spaceship
hope you catch him drop two all the
rockets oh okay well I've already got
one here
I'm already launching I'm gonna go up
into space I'm on my way
and guess who's I've got with me guess
who's I I've got with me
it's but wait it's Wade one Wade I got
the Wade this is a one-way trip ah very
ya better at something that Wade would
jaha oh that's a girl
that's the kind of quality pun that Wade
will make all right so anyway Oh once I
get back to earth all the way disease is
gonna spread around and then there's
gonna be hundreds of Wade's standing
everywhere cuz we can do that right get
over why the hell is it called
over that's what it's always been called
because there's net the nether and then
this is underworld all right I got a
parachute you did why am i parachuting
into the atmosphere
holding my rocket ship ha ha ha ha cuz
you're doesn't even make sense just that
strong man look my god is this a snow
biome oh no it's a desert are we gonna
land in the same place I really hope so
it's nighttime why why is that a thing
ha ha ha all right
I'm coming to get you and I've got wait
why is there a supply chest dropping
with in
parachute where are you Bob hahaha Bob
where are you I tell you about
everything I'm coming I got you
whoa that's a lot of monsters yeah
that's what I'm saying thanks for
clearing him out
oh oh I landed in sewage Oh Oh God
oh it's in my eyes oh oh the one patch
of sewage is the entire world huh I'll
let it right at it but what ah good Oh
God oh I'm being murdered a big murder
and I'm dying for Boise
I can't even sprit okay I'm off okay
why are there so many monsters this
doesn't seem appropriate
oh I'm gonna die save Wade there's so
many damn there's so many damn skeletons
around here okay Bob where'd you go
nowhere oh really
you mean right here hahahaha
you can't stop Wade oh hang on I'm doing
I'm I'm we're gonna survive it's gonna
be fine together okay
all right I'm not gonna let go Wade
that's fine just wait good to meet with
me forever
ah argh oh my god that's horrifying am i
yeah I can't even see myself too cramped
in here where am i where am i where am i
where am i I can't
it's oh there I am okay all right so
anyway what are we gonna do to survive
spoon I don't know spoon all right
that's okay just uh I hope millions of
pounds of TNT doesn't randomly spawn
around us I'll be horrible that would be
the worst I would hate that why are you
filling my inventory with rocket ships
this does not help me ow
wait a minute whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
did you whoa what is that what what what
what other crap gotta go
don't let it get in our hole
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha no no all right I
think that's enough shenanigans
whoo I found the cannon yeah how do you
fire empty how do you fire it I really
can't sit hoppin I don't know why is it
hoppin Oh broke okay there it is again
do you have ammo for it no no okay
I think that's enough shenanigans for
now it seems that we have lost Wade and
he is dead forever
our rescue mission was a gigantic
failure is that really even technically
a rescue mission if we're honest
well no but then again I don't know how
they turned him to sand so it's probably
all for the best
everyone please take a moment of silence
to thank Hey
I found him what ah look hey let's go
away - ha ha tyronn take a moment to
thank your lucky stars that Wade will
never be joining us ever again on
drawing my graft cuz he is dead forever
right well yeah let's go time a fitting
to my guess yeah let's do that one last
thing we'll build them a nice and a nice
nice tombstone
let's see what I'd wanted Wade like the
best well you know uh going [ __ ] ya ear
us does he rest at the base or the tip
that's the real quick oh that is it
put him right at the tip like like a
block up from the tip CONUS ah can you
give me some something to build my way
up there here you just make it like
extra three-dimensional here have a
bunch of have a bunch up pink wall I'm
not quiet
why ain't I picking it up I don't know
why ain't you why ain't you there you go
okay yeah I mean this is what he would
have wanted Ellie being honest you think
about it yeah if you think about it
really
OOP yep their rear lies Wade
oh wait a sign magically appeared on the
side of it what does it say bye
just wait hahahahahahaha yep
a fitting end into one giant douche Wade
there we go
you shall be missed uh-huh or you'll
return in like an episode or two I don't
know which but probably one of those is
gonna have one of those will definitely
happen so goodbye Wade and thank you
everybody so much for watching thanks
Bob for joining me no problem
bob has a twitter you can find zombie
was the moderator or whatever you want
to call him he was kind of the overseer
blah blah blah you know how this go so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more views that I've
done and as always we will see you in
the next video bye bye bye Bob ahh
close up here
even still
next what
having two garlic and he'll be attorney
grabbing dirty bearded for the curb
their reduced eyeballs ever get lifted
dog Morgan Morgan Susan come soon